حقائب تبدو عاديه من الخارج لكن ما
بداخلها قادر على افناء العالم حرفيا توجد
بداخلها ازرار وشفرات وبمجرد الضغط عليها
او ادخالها تتحرك اعتى جيوش العالم وتنطلق
خلال دقائق اقوى الصواريخ التي صنعها
الانسان
لتعلن نهايه البشريه انها الحقائب النوويه
في الولايات المتحده يطلق عليها كره القدم
النوويه وفي روسيا تسمى اليد الميته وفيها
كاسبيك او مفاتيح الجحيم اما هذا الرجل
فيبدو انه لا يحب الحقائب ويكفيه فقط زره
النووي على مكتبه الذي اعلن عنه عام 2018
كره القدم النوويه في الولايات المتحده
سميت بهذا الاسم بعد ازمه الصواريخ
الكوبيه وقتها برزت اهميه هذه الحقيبه
التي ترافق الرئيس اينما ذهب وتحتوي
الرموز والمفاتيح المخصصه للشن ضربه نوويه
وتوجد منها ثلاث نسخ موزعه بين الرئيس
ونائبه بينما يتم حفظ نسخه الثالثه في
البيت الابيض
كره القدم النوويه عباره عن حقيبه جلديه
سوداء وزنها حوالي 20 كلغ تضم بداخلها
اربعه عناصر هي كتاب اسود من 75 صفحه
يحتوي الاجراءات لتوجيه ضربه نوويه
انتقاميه وكتاب اسود اخر يتضمن قائمه
مواقع سريه امنه لايواء الرئيس في حال
تفعيل الهجوم وكتيب من عشر صفحات يتضمن
تعليمات حول كيفيه تشغيل نظام الطوارئ
وبطاقه ادخال تحويل شفره المصادقه على
الاطلاق بالاضافه الى شاشه وهوائيه صغير
يظهر من الحقيبه ومعدات اتصال متطوره
الحقيبه النوويه يتناوب على حملها خمسه
جنود امريكيين مدربين لاجل هذه المهمه
فحسب مسلحين بمسدسات من نوع بيريتا ولديهم
اوامر باطلاق النار على اي شخص يحاول
الاقتراب من الحقيبه
ويرافقون رئيس الولايات المتحده برا وبحرا
وجوا
القانون الامريكي يمنح الرئيس صلاحيه
حصريه في شن ضربه نوويه لكن بعد اجراءات
معينه بالطبع من الاتصال بمركز عمليه
وزاره الدفاع
والتاكد من انه هو بذاته من امر بالضربه
النوويه
حقيبه روسيا النوويه لا تقل رعبا عن
نظيرتها الامريكيه هنا يظهر رئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين وخلفه هذا العسكري الذي
يحمل الحقيبه النوويه التي تلقب في روسيا
باليد الميته انظمه الحقيبه قادره على
تدمير قاره كامله فلديها ما تسمى مفاتيح
الجحيم وهي عباره عن جهاز يحمل الشفرات
لتفعيل الترسانه النوويه الروسيه يمكنه
اطلاق الصواريخ الاستراتيجيه الروسيه من
اي مكان كالتي تم اطلاقها في عام 95 في
حادث صاروخ النرويجي حيث تم تفعيل الضربه
ردا على صاروخ اطلقه علما نرويجيون
وامريكيون وكانت تلك المره الوحيده التي
تنشط فيها الحقيبه النوويه الروسيه
استعدادا لهجوم نووي
الحقيبه النوويه الروسيه ظهرت لاول مره في
عام
1984 ومنذ ذلك الحين توجد منها ثلاث نسخ
بوتين يمتلك النسخه الاولى
وزير دفاعه لديه النسخه الثانيه اما
الثالثه فيمتلكها رئيس هيئه الاركان
العامه وتحوي بداخلها ازرارا مسؤوله عن
امر اطلاق اكثر من الف صاروخ تحمل رؤوسا
نوويه من اماكن مختلفه
في كوريا الشماليه الامر مختلف بعض الشيء
فالزم كيميونغ اون اكتفى بزر نووي على
مكتبه الشخصي يعني الضغط عليه بدايه جحيم
نووي لاعدائه
سواء كانت حقيبه ام زره تبقى الحقيقه
المرعبه ان هذه الوسائل الصغيره تستطيع
تدمير العالم وان مجرد دقائق قليله وربما
ثوان قد تحول بين استمرار الحياه او
الفناء الحتمي